the president's on the line just for
kicks and giggles i'm going to let leo
toro
i want you to tell the president in 30
seconds while you're voting for him
for a republican yes president trump i
want you to listen to me give me a call
later on
first time ever in my entire life as a
republican i'm voting for you
now maintain what you're doing in these
democratic cities and i'll go on those
other networks
and battle those guys for you you're
going to win in november i guarantee it
i'm out there with you 24 7. very much
and you've come a long way leo i have to
tell you i've been watching you
and i've always respected you even on
the other side
i'm here now i'm here right now
i'm here i appreciate it i do thank you
thank you thanks leah all right really
great geraldo thank you
damn all right i think that might have
been the funniest moment we've had mr
president sir thank you so much for
joining us i know it's been a busy
number of days here for you
um a lot of news to get to i want to
spend a lot of time on the violence the
safety security
of our cities i want to talk about
covert a lot
let's start with some breaking news and
that is that you
earlier today decided to pull back on
the convention in jacksonville
you gave a reason can you give us the
reasons again in more detail
well it's really the china virus call it
covid call it anyone of a lot of
different names but
you know we're setting an example we
don't want to have
people so close together we've had such
enthusiasm everybody wanted to go there
you know we went to north carolina we
wanted to do it there it was all set and
we're going to build a beautiful
facility and
it got hit hard and the governor then
really he uh
could have treated us better democrat
governor but
we are actually opening up there and
then we'll
make uh we'll make our ways it won't be
your typical convention i can say that
but it's going to be very safe and i
thought i had an obligation
not to have large numbers massive
numbers of people crowded into a room
i've been told mr president uh from
sources of mine
you can confirm if you like uh i guess
maybe
i'm not surprised that that you are
entertaining ideas that i have heard
tonight that would be pretty spectacular
would you give us any insight into what
they are well we have some ideas but
it'll have to be different than your
typical convention we have
just great enthusiasm in the party i
don't think we've ever had it
even more so than 2016 and you see
what's going on with the polls since
it's funny
since i did i made a speech at mount
rushmore
and since that time it's been really
something that's been
i mean before that really you have all
of these
fake these suppression polls that just
like uh 2016 when they put out these
phony polls
uh the media but i'll tell you what it's
uh that the
enthusiasm this party has and that they
have for
their president because we're keeping
our city safe we want to go and we can't
understand i heard you talking with
the group but really that's a group of a
great group of three people
but i heard you talking about the cities
and the safeties of the city
i've offered them all every one of them
and there's
ten of them we're offering all of them
let us go in we'll clean it up
we'll clean it up now in portland we had
to do it because that was
that's their anarchist that's even
that's a level that people haven't seen
but they're anarchists and
they were going wild for 51 days and we
went in
and they've done a great job they're
going to rip down the courthouse a big
federal courthouse gorgeous federal
courthouse
so we went in and we've been very very
strong and we have this
mayor whalen who i think is also he's
also
the police commissioner as i understand
it
yeah mayor wheeler and he's uh
he made a fool out of himself liz he
wanted to be among the people so he went
into the crowd and they knocked the hell
out of him
that was the end of him so it was pretty
uh pretty pathetic
but we want to go in and help the cities
we want to help chicago we want to help
all of them detroit's having problems
they're a very good police chief in
detroit but they have problems
we'll go into all of the cities any of
the cities we're ready we'll put in
50 000 60 thousand people that really
know what they're doing
and they're strong they're tough and we
could solve these problems so fast but
as you know we have to be invited in
that's the president i wanna ask you
about we're gonna have to do something
that's
much stronger than being invited in but
we have to be invited in go ahead sean
the acting dhs chief chad wolf there
there are statutory
reasons and justification to protect
federal buildings that is what has been
happening when you talk about 100 agents
we now have 15 mayors we see this rise
in homicides and shootings
one day right here on this program a
couple of nights ago
15 people shot in chicago last weekend
70 people shot
12 dead a 10 year old 11 year old shot
you spoke to horace lorenzo anderson
senior i know you invited him to the
white house he lost his 19 year old son
we lost an eight-year-old little girl
in in the chas autonomous zone in
atlanta
a one-year-old in brooklyn a
seven-year-old little beautiful young
girl in in chicago and they
you know one thing that all of these
cities have in common
they've been run by
liberal democratic mayors liberal
democratic governors
for decades what do you say to the
people
most people would argue you don't have a
chance of winning new york or illinois
or california
or washington state well you're right
they're run by
very liberal people you could say
radical left in some cases in some cases
just liberal democrats and
they're not taking care of their police
they're not respecting the police
the police do an incredible job it's a
very tough job it's a very dangerous job
and these mayors and by the way
governors and senators and
congressmen democrat congressmen they
want to pass stuff to
make the police less they want to take
all of their power away and you know
you'll have a
a bad situation where you'll have a bad
cop a very bad cop and
they they have no idea the problem they
cause but you have 99
great people that work hard and get paid
not nearly enough and
the job they do is incredible and uh
these
these people are just taking all of
their
respect they're taking their guts out
and it's a shame
it's a shame and you know the police
they could do the job in seattle
they could they knew that we were coming
in and they went in just before we got
there so we were all set to move
but if we weren't going to go in if they
thought that we weren't coming in it
would still be
bad but those police can do the job but
the mayor and
everybody tells them not to do it the
governor
they say not to do it and it's a
philosophy and
let me tell you if joe biden never got
in the whole country would be like that
you know we have a lot of great cities
we have a lot of very safe cities great
places
great states that don't have any
problems and they look at the things
that they see in chicago and they look
at
what they're witnessing in portland and
all of these different places and they
can't believe what's going on
but we have you know we have great
places but we have some
some instances that nobody's ever seen i
spoke with
the mayor of chicago mayor lightfoot
and i had a great talk but
within minutes after that talk you just
reported it tonight a couple of more
people were shot
young very young children were shot so
sad
and it's a shame it's a shame and we
could solve it if they invited us in
we'd go in with
50 000 75 000 people
we would be able to solve it like you
wouldn't believe and quick
but they just don't want to ask maybe
for political reasons
but they don't want to ask it's a
disgrace let me ask you mr president
uh i know a lot has been made over joe
biden and
his comments that he made i know he's
now backed off it and he says well i
said it before the other way
i don't know if he's just not
remembering what maybe somebody else
wrote in usa today for example but
he did say police have now become the
enemy
when they're supposed to help people and
any follow-up was would you
support reappropriating the money and he
said yes
now not using the term democrats seem to
be walking back the term defund but
reallocation is the word he used
well that would be the same thing let me
play it so to remind
our audience what he said
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement they don't need that
the last thing you need is an up armored
humvee coming into a neighborhood it's
like the military invading
they don't know anybody they become the
enemy they're supposed to protecting
these people
so my generic point is that do we agree
that we can redirect some of the funding
yes absolutely one of the things that we
also need to be doing
is fundamentally changing the way and
i've been pushing it for years
changing the way we deal with our prison
system
mr president i could remind people
you're the one that did criminal justice
reform
biden is vice president barack they did
not you did police reform
they did not uh you also set record
after record low unemployment they added
13 million more americans to food stamps
8 million more in poverty
and the lowest labor participation rate
since the 70s you set record low after
record low for every demographic group
then we got opportunity zones your
biggest commitment in terms of money and
length of time to historically black
colleges they didn't do any of those
things
uh your answer to what joe biden now is
now he's adopting
the position of the yeah police of the
enemy he's never said a good word
bolshevik bernie's economic agenda aoc's
new green deal agenda
he's pledging trillions of taxpayer
dollars
and add to that uh let's see beto
o'rourke
and pelosi schumer and biden 125 years
in the swamp your reaction to his team
well it's all true but one of the things
you mentioned and he mentioned was the
surplus military equipment
and when i came in as soon as i came in
i distributed to all of the police
departments all over the nation
we had hundreds of millions of dollars
of sometimes
new but it was never going to be used it
was sitting in warehouses all over the
u.s
and i delivered it all to police free of
charge all to police it was just growing
dust it was just
uh just sitting there just i guess
paying
rent or whatever they were doing and all
these massive warehouses and i got it
all
out to the police and they were so
thankful
and you know a lot of it was protective
equipment and they didn't want to do it
because they thought the police looked
too strong
that it was sending a wrong signal to
the police but it was really protecting
the police
and there was offensive capability but
there was a lot of protective capability
and it was uh really amazing to me what
that
they wouldn't deliver it they wouldn't
they wouldn't do it and i
and i've gotten notes i've gotten so
many notes from the heads of the police
departments and even from the the cops
just the guys on the beat thanking me
for all of the equipment that we sent
out and we were never going to use it it
was growing old and growing dusty
so that's a whole different way of
thinking but
and and you know when he when you talk
about the bernie sanders thing
i think what joe biden
and i don't think it was him i think it
was radical left people that are totally
controlling him like a puppet i don't
think it's him i don't think he
knows even what we're talking about but
when we talk about biden
he's got a manifesto that he agreed to i
caught a manifesto with bernie sanders
for open borders and things that you
wouldn't even believe i mean
these are left wing at a level
that i don't think bernie ever talked
about to the same extent
you'd think this is negotiation that
bernie would be brought to the right a
little bit
i think bernie went further left and
o'biden agreed to all of this stuff
let me ask you sir i've been in talk
radio for 33 years believe it or not
since i began that journey i've been
blessed to work here at fox i'm now
in my 25th year here uh politics is a
passion of mine
uh usually you have candidates you're
probably an exception what you say
what you said in 2016 is what you did
you many ways
people haven't figured out you're very
predictable in the sense that if you say
you mean it
in my view but usually people run to the
base for the
primary and then they run to the center
joe biden
has adopted bolshevik bernie's
radical socialism aoc's new green deal
we're talking about trillions of dollars
he's now committing to
both those things redistribution higher
taxes
then i mentioned beto o'rourke and then
schumer pelosi
and biden have had 20 125 years why
in this case do you believe he's going
harder left than any candidate i've ever
seen in my lifetime for sure
because i think he's afraid of the
people on his left i think that
when these are very radicalized people i
mean he's gone
so far he's given bernie everything
bernie can't even believe it i heard
bernie's going around saying i can't
believe what we got
and this was a negotiation that was done
very quickly
and today i saw president obama with him
and remember this i wouldn't be there if
it weren't for those two
if they did a good job i wouldn't you
know like ran i ran against what they
did
and i won and nobody campaigned harder
than president obama somebody said oh
obama's coming and i said that's okay we
beat him the last time
i think he campaigned harder than
hillary clinton did you want to know the
truth remember i'd always talk about
there comes air force one
obama was all over the place but the
fact is
biden and obama i'm here i'm in the
white house
because of them if they did a good job
people forget
but if they did a good job and except
for the china virus that came in
we were setting every record you could
set for unemployment for
uh the stock market every single record
you could imagine
and then what we did we rebuilt the
military we got rid of regulations at a
level that no administration
even in eight years or in one case more
than that
no administration's come close and we've
appointed you know we will have
almost it could even be more but almost
300 federal judges appointed
by the end of my first term that's a
record nobody's ever done anything like
that
and two supreme court judges great ones
all right
let me go to joe biden uh
i argue and i've i've watched this and
witnessed this
my whole professional life i think that
the job you have i believe
regardless of who's president is the
hardest job in the world
uh you have a lot of a lot of burdens on
your shoulder anybody that's president
and i think when they asked reagan in
1984 and they questioned whether or not
he had the
mental alertness the strength the
stamina to do the job it was a fair
question
he answered it in one line in the second
debate against mondale
let me play some of the greatest hits of
biden
and then biden from yesterday and
i want to i want your take on what is
going on
with joe biden let's play it first
scale scale of the loss is
staggering i don't know who spelling
that is but the scale of the loss is
staggering
it's been two months since congress gave
them that money either just me
okay
good evening thanks so much for tuning
in
look tomorrow's superstar tuesday and i
want to thank you all
i tell you what i'm rushing ahead aren't
i we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the
you know the thing my name is joe biden
i'm a democratic candidate for the
united states senate
look me over if you'd like to see help
out if you agree with me
go to joe 303
30. we choose truth over facts
play the radio make sure the television
excuse me
make sure you have the record player on
at night the
the phone make sure the kids hear words
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talented white kids
donald trump does pose an excellent
strength to this
the it's not hypothetical why in god's
name should someone who's clipping
coupons in the stock market
make in fact pay a lower tax rate than
someone who in fact is
uh like i said a school teacher and a
firefighter
i'm sorry i'm confused who i'm talking
to here but anyway whoever it is
and i had a nurse at uh nurses
at uh walter reed hospital who would
bend down and
whisper in my ear wow and go home and
get me pillows they would make sure
they'd actually
probably nothing ever taught in you
can't do it in the covert time but
they'd actually breathe in my nostrils
to make me move
wearing a mask is now a political
statement this is more patriotic
why do you wear the mask so you don't
make somebody else
sick sick
what's with this guy steve that's our
time okay
mr president um i'm not a doctor i won't
play one
uh i don't i think joe biden has aged
dramatically
since he's left office um he doesn't
seem very alert he's they seem to be
protecting him and hiding we now have
interviews that are being shut off by
handlers what's your reaction sir
well in all fairness i know people that
are 90 91 92 that are sharp as attack
uh bernie marcus as an example home
depot and and others i know
numerous but uh you know i i just it's
hard to comment on somebody
he's an opponent uh you have to be
very sharp i'm dealing with the heads of
these countries and every one of them is
a world-class chess player
and if you're not 100 on your game if
you're not 100
uh sharp plus you got a problem i look
i looked at what we have in this country
i came in and i i
guessed it from before but after i saw
what was going on with
horrible trade deals horrible military
deals
money being spent it was being sent out
like water you see what i've done with
nato 140 billion dollars but really much
more than that
it increases every year where countries
are now
paying for what we're doing it was so
unfair so many different things i could
go on you don't have enough time i could
go all night with it
but you have to be on your game you have
to be sharp and you have to be tough
and if you're not these guys are going
to take you to the cleaner
and they will take you to the cleaners
like you've never seen before
it's so easy and uh
he wasn't he wasn't the best in his
heyday
let's not kid ourselves everybody knows
that everybody knows
senators will tell you that in his best
he wasn't but
but i see the statements he's making now
and i don't think he has much of a clue
mr president when you spoke about
canceling the convention in jacksonville
you you were very passionate about it
today
and you said the timing is not right uh
and we knew there would be flare-ups uh
this virus is the worst since 1918
and you said today i have to protect the
american people that's what i've always
done that's what i always will d
will be will do that's what i'm about uh
we can make this work easily and you
also reminded people
the importance of masks people say you
haven't been as outspoken as maybe you
should have on mass but
there were people telling us well-known
experts
not to wear masks in march for crying
out loud and socially distancing
and the cdc just released last week that
if people wear the masks
this thing could be gone in four to six
weeks and what can you add about
therapeutics and what can you add about
a potential vaccine you mentioned pfizer
today
well you know at the beginning many
people many very respected people i
won't mention names but many respected
people were saying
don't wear a mask that they're bad you
touch your face too much and
you get your hands near your eyes and
your nose and their bed
and then all of a sudden uh it was a big
thing to get messed because i'm all for
it
look whatever's going to help if it was
a 5
chance or 2 chance wear it and i'll wear
it i wore
at walter reed hospital the other day i
went to the hospital i visited soldiers
that have been so badly
injured in iraq and uh it's
terrible in afghanistan i saw one that
was so badly
injured in afghanistan and you know
we're largely we're down to
a very small force in both places we
were serving as policemen over there and
we can police our own country especially
when you look at chicago and you look at
what's happening around our country and
uh you know we've we've done a lot we've
done a lot
but uh you have to we have to do we have
to get our country back
we have to get rid of this horrible
plague that hit us
and it hit us hard but it didn't hit
just us it hit the whole world sean
the whole world was hit china allowed it
to escape
to europe and to the whole world
including us
and they're suffering this tremendous
you know you don't see that too much in
the news but you have countries that are
going through relatively uh what we're
doing
plus plus plus it's horrible and we make
ventilators because we've become
we've become the best in the world for
the ventilators we're making thousands a
month
we're we're sending supplies all over
and we're
we're in great shape from the standpoint
but we have this thing that's
very very contagious nobody's ever seen
anything like it
very very highly contagious but if you
take a look at a map we have
large sections of the country that are
in great shape
and we're going to win and we're going
to win sooner rather than later
i will say this on the vaccines we're
doing very well we have the greatest
companies in the world including we're
dealing with other
nations we're working very closely
and therapeutically therapeutics are
i think going to be fantastic frankly
i'd like to have that first because you
could go into the hospitals give
somebody a shot
or do whatever you have to do and they'd
get better right away
but we're doing very well
therapeutically and we're doing very
very well with vaccines
well we know new studies have come out
and i had dr oz on my radio show this
week uh
that hydroxychloroquine used early with
the zithromycin and
zinc and you took a lot of heat over it
uh mortality rate cut in half according
to the ford study
he mentioned a local hospital
retrospective study in new york
let me ask you you tweeted out tonight
baseball is back
uh by the way poor dr fauci and i really
do believe
and people i think try to divide both of
you uh
that he he's tried his best dr burks has
tried her best
um all the models and experts in many
many ways were so
wrong the one thing that remained
consistent is the most vulnerable
the elderly those were compromised
conditions or immune systems and
pre-pre-existing conditions
so i ask you you know where are we with
the vaccine the therapeutics how soon
and do you want every american if they
can't socially distant to wear the mask
i i selfishly want baseball football to
open so we can go and
i also want to protect grandmas and
grandpas
i'd like to see everybody if they can't
spread if they can't have
be socially distant then i think they
should probably put it on
and even if it's let's say it's a
50 chance or 25 because again people
these same experts were saying don't
wear it at one point now they're saying
where
so let's go with them what difference
does it make we got to get rid of this
thing so let's say they're right and
let's say there's a 50
chance or 25 chance i'm not going to
lose with it you're not going to lose
with it so do it
but again as i said i really think
you're going to have some
answers very very soon on therapeutics
and also in vaccines
these companies i'm dealing with them
directly i'm getting reports directly
they're very far advanced they've
already started testing
and what i've done is through the fda dr
han and some great people
we have ramped it up to a level that
nobody's ever seen speed like this
we could be two or three years out
before we're doing what we do we're
already testing we are actually doing
the testing
for vaccines and for therapeutics that
would have happened in a normal
administration i will say that
that would have happened in two and
three years from now
so we're way way advanced and i think
you're going to have some very good
answers
very soon and they're going to come up
with the answer mr president
you're asking the american people in 103
days well some will be voting early
by the way i have information on my
website hannity.com early voting
how do you do absentee voting uh who
your congress person is it's up for
election
in 103 days i say the american people
the ultimate jury
you're asking the american people for
four more years
if you're given the four more years what
will this country look like in your view
four years from now so
it's all going to be about america first
we always put other countries before us
which is so foolish and so horrible and
it's been so destructive for us it's
about america first we'll help other
countries
but we want to take care of ourselves
we're going to be building
factories we're going to be bringing in
jobs like you've never seen we were all
set to do it until we got hit with the
virus
our troops will be home the endless wars
are already ending
down to very few soldiers and as you
know in afghanistan
very few in iraq syria is largely out
except we kept the oil we have oil there
that we kept i didn't want to leave the
oil we kept it
yeah we took it over uh we're going to
be about jobs like you haven't seen
we're going to be respected and we are
now by other countries they're
respecting us more than they have in
many many decades i will tell you that
we're going to have a wall that's
complete we're up to 257 miles on the
new wall and by the way
if we didn't have that wall in right now
you would have
numbers in texas and in california and
new mexico like you wouldn't believe
but we built uh 257 miles of
it's 450 but we're going to do about 537
miles all together that'll
give a complete beautiful wall on our
southern border that's really helped and
the other thing is
we're going to start making our product
and i've been pushing this from before
this happened
we're going to make things here we're
going to make them here right now china
and many other countries are doing what
we're supposed to be doing
they went they became globalists these
great geniuses became globalists
and they really hurt our country we're
going to start
making it here i was with elon musk i
said elon build a factory in texas he
just announced today they're building
one of the biggest plants in the world
auto plant
for tesla and it's going to be in texas
and you know it's great he called me up
just a little while ago to say i got it
done
so that meaning he got it done but i was
i was pushing that job very hard from
elon because we work with him and we do
a lot for him and i said
it's time and he was he was great he's
doing a good job
but the other thing we've done is space
force you know we put in this the first
time in 76 years
we have a new force we have so important
the army navy air force marines coast
guard
and now we have the air force it's so
great
and it's so important it's going to end
up being one of my at first
i didn't even talk about that in the
campaign this was after i got in office
i realized we need it
because china and russia were going to
dominate space
and we can't let that and now we're
going to be dominating space they're not
too happy about
what we did with air force but we have
it and uh with
with space force so we have now space
force
so important and so many other things
showing regulation cuts tax cuts biggest
tax cuts in history
biggest regulation cuts in history and
we're going to continue that forward
there are still many things we can do
but the bottom line is we're
we're putting america first and we're
making america better than it's ever
been
you will see that we're going to have a
great year next year we're gonna have a
great third quarter
and the nice thing about the third
quarter is the results are going to come
out
before the election you know
i've been saying to my audience from
radio and tv that
this is the biggest choice election in
our lifetime it's literally
you know taxes higher or lower
deregulation more regulation
law and order lawlessness amnesty or
or border security judges uh
energy trade foreign policy it seems
like you're running against the team and
the team is
joe bernie bolshevik bernie i call him
bernie sanders the socialist
aoc green new deal beto schumer pelosi
so i think it is
i i want to go back to baseball you
announced today you're going to throw
out the first pitch at yankee stadium on
august 15th
dr fauci did not do too well tonight
with the nationals
have you ever thrown out a first pitch
before are you nervous about throwing
out the first
pitch derek jeter once famously said i
guess to george bush after 9 11.
uh if you bounce it you're going to get
booed
yeah no i have thrown out first pictures
i've agreed to do it for the yankees uh
on uh
i think they're playing the boston red
sox that's a great rivalry and
i will do it it's great that baseball's
back and other sports are back
i hope everyone's standing i hope
they're not going to be kneeling when
the flag is raised i don't like to see
that that would hurt that would hurt a
lot of people in our country they don't
want to see that with the nfl or
baseball or
basketball or anything else we want to
there are plenty of places you can
protest you don't have to protest
on the raising of our flag so uh
a lot of great things happening for our
country one other thing i want to say is
we've made incredible trade deals and
we're going to continue that along
because we got taken to the cleaners by
every country
ally or non-ally we were taken to the
cleaners
and we'll keep that going mr president
mark meadows your chief of staff
recently indicated that indictments
could be imminent in the durham
probe we had big breaking news tonight i
don't know if you saw the opening of the
show
a document declassified by your director
of national intelligence john ratcliffe
revealing the fbi agent who gave you
that defensive briefing in
august of 2016 used it as a cover
to monitor you and michael flynn as it
relates to
to russia do you remember it it also i
believe
puts jim comey in a position of being
proven to have lied
just like when he said to you at trump
tower the dossier
is salacious but unverified but he swore
that it was
accurate and true when he signed the
fisa application to spy on you and your
campaign
and take away carter page's rights uh
what is your reaction to this news and
your thoughts on where this probe with
john durham's going
well it's just more and more things that
you see and that's only what you see
it is really bad it's a terrible thing
that happened should never happen to
another president the fact is that
president obama and vice president biden
and the whole group of
with brennan and comey and mccabe and
lisa
page and strzok her lover and beyond
them long beyond them they spied on the
campaign
using the intelligence agencies of our
country they illegally this is illegal
as can be this is
uh treason this is many things you can
call it they spied on the campaign
of another party both before
and after victory both before and after
never been done before it is so bad it
with the other side they would have been
in jail for two years and it would have
been a 50-year term
but obama and biden knew everything and
they spied on the campaign
of the opposing party using intelligence
do you uh well this raises a question
now we know what happened in the oval
office on january 5th
do you think that barack obama the
former president
joe biden should have to answer for what
we now know
happened 15 days before your
inauguration in the oval office we have
one minute sir that was just one meeting
there were many meetings there was no
way i understand the system very well
i don't understand being president very
well there was no way this could have
gone out without and gunned down without
president obama knowing every single
thing
and even biden brought up the logan act
with respect to general flynn a great
gentleman who's been treated so horribly
and still is a lot of a lot of things
have been learned and what happened is a
disgrace again
should never ever happen when you
consider
pardons for the people involved in the
last 15 seconds
i've looked at a lot of different people
they've been treated extremely unfairly
and i think i probably would yes
mr president thank you for your time in
103 days the american people will make
the ultimate decision
sir we appreciate you always taking time
for this audience thank you
thank you very much john thank you